the Kuwaiti dinar is a national currency
of the country of Kuwait and currently
it will cost you three dollars and 28
cents to just get a single Kuwaiti dinar
making it the most valued currency in
the world not only is it the most valued
currency but also want the most
consistent as it has held this title for
decades considering this
how is Kuwait able to create such a
strong currency and maintain it for all
this time but Before we jump into that
we have to first understand the
different types of exchange rates which
are floating fixed and mixed floating
exchange rates like the name suggests
are linked to market activity it is
dependent on the GDP of a country cuddle
money in circulation exports imports
government spending unemployment rate
the stock market and a multitude of
other factors none of these factors
directly impact a country's currency
exchange rate but they all play a role
in influencing the exchange rate you see
exchange rates are based on a currency
supply and demand on the foreign
exchange market which is basically the
stock market of currencies when more
investors want your currency because all
of the reasons that I just mentioned
your exchange rate will go up and the
exact opposite is true as well when
investors don't want your currency your
exchange rate or fall the vast majority
of countries in the world use this
system and fluctuations in a currency
exchange rate are usually quite
indicative of how much an investor wants
a specific currency for instance the
Venezuelan Bulevar exchange rate has
sunk into ground as a country fights
ever increasing inflation evidently
currently a Venezuelan Bulevar is only
worth less than 5% of what it was worth
one year ago
considering this does this mean that
kuwait has one of the most sought-after
currencies in the world well this is
simply not true as they are one of the
few countries that use a peg exchange
rate model a pegged or fixed exchange
rate is simply two ratmir countries
exchange rate based on other countries
performance and as a result the success
of a given currency is directly
dependent
upon the performance of another currency
for instance I could create a currency
right now and peg it to the US dollar
meaning I can determine the exchange
rate I can say that each unit in my
currency is worth five US dollars of
course the value of my currency would
fluctuate as the US dollar goes up and
down however my currency will always be
equivalent to five US dollars but simply
doing this doesn't mean anything as
people from other countries actually
have the value exchange rate and buy
stuff from your country for it to
actually be a valid currency otherwise
sure you could have a high exchange rate
but it wouldn't have any validity so how
was the Kuwaiti dinar able to build
traffic for its currency well as you may
have already guessed this is all
possible due to Kuwait's rich or
reserves in fact 80% of the Kuwaiti
government's revenue comes from
petroleum-based products this enables
Kuwait to maintain a consistent source
of traffic for its exports on top of
this over the years cuvee has had two
consistent updates currency in order to
keep it at the top wanting to replace
her old currency the Gulf rupee the
Kuwaiti currency board created a new
currency called the Kuwaiti dinar and it
was originally pegged to the British
pound but as I said before an issue with
pegging currency is that your currency
is only as strong as the currency your
peg to and in late 1970s and early 1980s
the exchange rate of the pound plummeted
anticipating this fall Kuwait's currency
board was quick to switch to a peg on a
basket of currencies instead of just one
this allowed them to be less susceptible
to fluctuations in the exchange rate of
any one country
this system lasted all the way up to
2003 when Kuwait decided to pay the
currency to the u.s. dollar at an
exchange rate of approximately three
dinars for one u.s. dollar but right
before the subprime housing crisis Kawai
reversed back to a basket of currencies
and that is what they are still using so
what does all of this mean well not much
really as since their currency is pegged
their current exchange rate has nothing
to do with the strength
of their economy and this would be true
even if it was a floating currency
exchange rate and a perfect example of
this is the South Korean Won a single US
dollar is equivalent to over 1100 South
Korean Won but this doesn't indicate a
big currency as a South Korean economy
is one of the strongest in the world
this disproportionately low exchange
rate can be explained by South Korea's
avoidance of decimal values a single
Korean Won is basically a cent as that
is the smallest currency value in South
Korea it's like if the US stopped using
the dollar and decided to calculate
everything in cents this would lead to a
euro being equivalent to 109 cents as
opposed to one dollar and nine cents as
you can see now the currency has gained
or lost value it's simply a different
type of currency similarly the Kuwaiti
dinars high comparative value doesn't
mean anything as good to simply relative
a price in the country so in the end
kuwait was able to create the highest
valcon C in the world by simply using as
all revenue as an appeal for traffic and
then pegging our currency against the
most consistent currencies during a
given time period so next time you see a
highly valid currency make sure not to
assume that this means wealth and
prosperity as a value of a country's
currency is a bad measure of a country's
economic performance if you guys thought
this video explained how Kuwait created
the world's most vital currency then
make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if we like to see more
questions just like this one logically
answered but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one